bienvenido de nuevo a comprender la información y la computación cuántica, mi nombre es John Watrous y soy el director técnico de educación en IBM
Quantum, esta es la décima lección de la serie y es la segunda lección de la tercera unidad, que trata sobre la formulación general
de la información cuántica. Esta lección trata sobre los canales, que representan cambios en
sistemas que almacenan información cuántica. Esto incluye operaciones útiles como las realizadas por
gates unitarias y Quantum circuits, así como cambios que quizás preferiríamos evitar, como el ruido. También podemos describir las mediciones
como canales, y eso es algo de lo que hablaremos en la próxima lección. El término canal nos llega de
la teoría de la información, que entre otras cosas estudia la capacidad de transmisión de información de los canales de comunicación con ruido.
Cuando pensamos en canales, estamos pensando de forma abstracta sobre los canales de comunicación.
Puede parecer algo extraño pensar en un cálculo complejo como un canal de comunicación, pero necesitamos una
palabra para referirnos a la noción general de un proceso que cambia la información de alguna manera, y para bien o para mal, la palabra
canal se ha quedado, sin duda en gran parte debido al enorme impacto que la teoría de la información y en particular el
trabajo de Claude Shannon en la década de 1940 ha tenido en la información y la computación cuántica. Aquí hay un resumen de la
lección: empezaremos con los conceptos básicos, incluida la definición de qué es un canal, así como cómo las operaciones unitarias en la formulación simplificada
de la información cuántica pueden describirse como canales. También hablaremos sobre el hecho de que las combinaciones convexas de canales son canales, y si te estás
preguntando por qué esta noción de convexidad sigue apareciendo, es porque realmente es una noción matemática fundamentalmente importante en la teoría de
la información cuántica. También veremos algunos ejemplos de canales, específicamente canales qubit, que reaparecerán de vez en
cuando a lo largo del resto de la lección. En la segunda parte de la lección, hablaremos sobre tres formas distintas en que podemos representar los canales
matemáticamente, y en particular hablaremos sobre las representaciones de Stinespring, las representaciones de Kraus y las representaciones de Choi,
que llevan el nombre de tres personas cuyo trabajo fue importante en el desarrollo de estas diferentes representaciones. En la tercera y
última parte de la lección, discutiremos una demostración matemática que establece que estas tres representaciones son de hecho equivalentes, así como el hecho de que
todas caracterizan correctamente la definición de qué es un canal. Es una demostración matemática realmente genial en mi opinión, y espero que aporte algo de
claridad sobre estas diferentes presentaciones, cómo se relacionan y cómo funcionan en general. Empezaremos con los conceptos básicos y
abordaremos la pregunta: ¿qué son los canales? Como ya sugerí al inicio de la lección, los canales describen cambios,
específicamente cambios en tiempo discreto en sistemas que almacenan información cuántica. Aquí, cuando nos referimos a un tiempo discreto,
simplemente estamos pensando en un cambio que ocurre entre dos momentos distintos en el tiempo, en contraste con un
proceso continuo, por ejemplo, que tiene sentido pensar en términos de períodos de tiempo infinitesimalmente pequeños. Los canales incluyen operaciones útiles como
operaciones unitarias realizadas por Quantum gates y circuits, así como cambios debidos al ruido. Sin embargo, a los efectos
de esta lección, principalmente vamos a pensar en los canales en términos matemáticos abstractos, y no habrá ninguna necesidad particular
de distinguir entre lo que es útil y lo que no. Los nombres típicos para los canales incluyen las letras griegas mayúsculas fi,
psi y xi, y usaremos diferentes letras para referirnos a algunos canales específicos. En una situación simple en la que
tenemos algún sistema en un estado descrito por alguna matriz de densidad rho y aplicamos un canal fi a ese sistema, el
resultado es un sistema cuyo estado está descrito por la matriz de densidad fi de rho. Entonces estamos pensando en un
canal fi dado como una función que puede aplicarse a matrices de densidad de un tamaño particular, o en otras palabras,
matrices de densidad de un sistema particular al que estamos aplicando este canal. Hay un par de requisitos que los canales deben cumplir para ser
considerados canales válidos. En primer lugar, los canales son mapeos lineales. Esto es completamente análogo a la situación que tenemos tanto
en la formulación simplificada de la información cuántica, donde las operaciones sobre vectores de estado cuánticos son necesariamente lineales, como
en la formulación estándar de la información clásica, donde las operaciones probabilísticas son lineales. Podrías cuestionar este requisito básico
de linealidad si realmente quisieras, pero si queremos una teoría que sea consistente tanto con la teoría de la probabilidad
como con la elección de representar los estados cuánticos con matrices de densidad, entonces realmente no tenemos otra opción y simplemente debemos aceptar que los canales son lineales.
El segundo requisito es que los canales transformen matrices de densidad en matrices de densidad. Eso tiene mucho sentido, porque si hemos elegido representar
los estados de los sistemas con matrices de densidad y aplicamos un canal a un sistema que está en algún estado, entonces el resultado tiene que ser un estado válido y por lo tanto
representado por una matriz de densidad. Hay un punto muy importante que añadir aquí, y es que este requisito
debe ser cierto no solo si aplicamos un canal a un sistema aislado cuyo estado está descrito por una matriz de densidad,
sino también si tenemos un sistema compuesto cuyo estado está descrito por alguna matriz de densidad y aplicamos el canal solo a
una parte de ese sistema. Esos son los requisitos que imponemos a los canales, y podemos ver que son muy
análogos a los requisitos que tenemos para las operaciones tanto en la formulación simplificada de la información cuántica como en la formulación estándar
de la información clásica. En la formulación simplificada de la información cuántica, las operaciones están representadas por matrices unitarias porque
corresponden precisamente a los mapeos lineales que siempre transforman vectores de estado cuántico en vectores de estado cuántico para un
sistema dado. De manera similar, las operaciones probabilísticas están representadas por matrices estocásticas, porque son las que
siempre transforman vectores de probabilidad en vectores de probabilidad. Aquí trabajamos con matrices de densidad y hay
este requisito adicional relativo a los sistemas compuestos, que resulta no ser necesario para los vectores de estado cuántico
ni para los vectores de probabilidad, pero de lo contrario los requisitos son análogos y en cierto sentido nos son impuestos por la elección
de representar los estados cuánticos mediante matrices de densidad. Aquí hay algunos detalles adicionales sobre los canales, incluida una convención
sobre cómo pensaremos en los sistemas de entrada y salida de un canal a lo largo de la lección, así como más detalles
sobre el requisito de que los canales siempre transformen matrices de densidad en matrices de densidad. En primer lugar, se asume que cada canal
tiene un sistema de entrada y un sistema de salida. Podemos nombrar estos sistemas como queramos, pero a lo largo de esta
lección voy a usar el nombre X para referirme al sistema de entrada y el nombre Y para referirme al sistema de salida. Conceptualmente, el canal
transforma el sistema de entrada en el sistema de salida, por lo que los sistemas de entrada y salida nunca coexisten simultáneamente.
Empezamos con X, se aplica o realiza el canal, y el resultado es que X ha sido transformado en Y, cuyo estado es
determinado por el mapeo lineal asociado con el canal. Los sistemas de entrada y salida de un canal no tienen que ser iguales y, en particular,
no tienen que tener el mismo número de estados clásicos. Sin embargo, puede ocurrir que los sistemas de entrada y salida sean en realidad el mismo sistema, o en otras
palabras, X es igual a Y, en cuyo caso simplemente estamos imaginando que fi está cambiando el estado del sistema, y de hecho esto es
muy a menudo la situación que nos interesa, pero esta posibilidad es consistente con el primer punto en el sentido de que nunca tenemos el
los sistemas de entrada y salida existiendo como dos sistemas separados al mismo tiempo y en cualquier caso va a ser conveniente para
los propósitos de esta lección usar letras diferentes, concretamente X e Y, para referirnos a los sistemas de entrada y salida
solo para ayudarnos a mantener las cosas claras. Ahora vamos a entrar en un poco más de detalle sobre el requisito de que los canales siempre transformen matrices de densidad
en matrices de densidad. Supongamos que introducimos un nuevo sistema Z en el panorama. Vamos a
darle el nombre gamma al conjunto de estados clásicos de este nuevo sistema. Imagina ahora que formamos un nuevo sistema compuesto ZX
que consiste en el nuevo sistema junto con el sistema de entrada X de un canal fi, y supongamos que este sistema compuesto está
en un estado descrito por una matriz de densidad row. Este puede ser un estado cuántico arbitrario de este par, pero sea cual sea el estado
siempre es posible expresar la matriz de densidad row en la forma que se muestra en pantalla, donde tanto A como B
recorren el conjunto de estados clásicos gamma y cada row AB es alguna matriz cuyas filas y columnas corresponden a lo que sea que
sea el conjunto de estados clásicos de X, y no necesitamos darle un nombre a ese conjunto de estados clásicos en este punto. Solo para ser claros, cada row AB no es necesariamente una
matriz de densidad por sí sola, pero la matriz row completa es necesariamente una matriz de densidad. Cuando aplicamos el canal fi a
el sistema X, este se transforma en Y, y así nos quedamos con el par ZY. La forma en que determinamos el
estado de este par después de aplicar fi solo a X es evaluar el mapeo lineal fi en cada una de las matrices row a
otra forma de decir esto es que tomamos el producto tensorial del mapeo fi con el mapeo identidad sobre matrices cuadradas que tienen filas y columnas
correspondientes a gamma, y eso a su vez equivale a no hacer nada a este nuevo sistema Z, pero esta es una descripción equivalente
y no requiere entrar en ningún detalle sobre productos tensoriales de mapeos de esta forma. Estos
sin embargo funcionan de una forma bastante sencilla, análoga a cómo funcionan para vectores y matrices. Una forma de pensar en esto visualmente es
en términos de matrices en bloques, y si hacemos la suposición simplificadora de que el conjunto de estados clásicos gamma consiste en los
enteros entre 0 y N menos uno para algún entero positivo M, entonces se vuelve fácil escribir todo esto como se
muestra aquí. Y ahora, para reiterar el requisito que estamos imponiendo sobre fi para que sea un canal válido, siempre debemos obtener una matriz de densidad
de este proceso, y esto debe ser cierto independientemente de qué elección hagamos para el sistema Z, así como la
elección que hagamos para row, siempre que sea una matriz de densidad. Eso puede parecer un requisito bastante estricto y
también puede parecer muy difícil de verificar, pero como veremos al final de la lección, en realidad no es tan estricto
ni difícil de verificar y, en particular, tenemos caracterizaciones matemáticas elegantes para esta condición
que están conectadas con las diferentes representaciones de las que hablaremos un poco más adelante en la lección. Ahora veamos algunos ejemplos de canales
comenzando con una categoría entera de canales llamados canales unitarios. En términos simples, estos son operaciones unitarias
igual que las que tenemos en la formulación simplificada de la información cuántica, vistas como canales. Para ser precisos, supongamos que U es una matriz unitaria
que representa una operación unitaria sobre un sistema X. Así que en la formulación simplificada de la información
cuántica multiplicaríamos esta matriz por un vector de estado cuántico dado para determinar la acción que esa operación tiene sobre ese estado cuántico. La
forma en que esto funciona para matrices de densidad es que multiplicamos la matriz de densidad por la izquierda por U y por la derecha por U
dagger. En términos matemáticos nos referimos a esta operación como conjugación por la matriz U. Esto es consistente con KSI
brasai siendo la matriz de densidad que describe el estado representado por el vector de estado cuántico s, y es bastante
fácil verificar que, en particular, si aplicáramos U al vector de estado cuántico Ki, obtendríamos U * Ki y su
representación como matriz de densidad está dada por ese vector multiplicado por su transpuesta conjugada, que es U * Ki * brasai * U
dagger. Cuando evaluamos la transpuesta conjugada de U * Ki. Así que la forma en que se define este canal
tiene sentido para estados puros y, cuando combinamos esto con la linealidad, vemos que tiene sentido para matrices de densidad en
general, debido al hecho de que toda matriz de densidad puede expresarse como una combinación convexa de estados puros. Esta
definición siempre nos da un canal válido para cualquier elección de una operación unitaria u. En particular, conjugar por
una matriz unitaria de esta forma no cambia la traza de una matriz, y si conjugamos cualquier matriz semidefinida positiva
por cualquier matriz, obtendremos otra matriz semidefinida positiva, y es bastante fácil obtener eso
directamente de la definición de matrices semidefinidas positivas. Así que las matrices de densidad siempre se mapean a matrices de densidad
y todo esto sigue siendo cierto incluso si tomamos el producto tensorial de U con la matriz identidad de cualquier tamaño, lo cual equivale
a aplicar este canal solo a una parte de un sistema compuesto. Aquí hay un ejemplo muy simple de un canal unitario. Supongamos que
tomamos U como la matriz identidad. Este es obviamente un canal válido llamado el canal identidad. No hacer
nada en absoluto es ciertamente una operación lineal y si comenzamos con una matriz de densidad y no hacemos nada,
seguirá siendo una matriz de densidad, así que este es un canal válido. La gente usa diferentes símbolos para denotar este canal:
a veces es exactamente el mismo símbolo que usamos para la matriz identidad, lo cual puede ser un poco confuso, pero generalmente no lo es. Aquí estoy usando las
letras ID, abreviatura de identidad, solo para evitar cualquier confusión, y esta notación también es bastante común. Puede parecer un
canal muy aburrido, pero en el contexto de la transmisión de información es en realidad un canal perfecto donde el
receptor recibe exactamente lo que el emisor envía, que es típicamente lo que uno más desea en ese contexto. Otra forma en que podemos
obtener muchos ejemplos de canales es tomando combinaciones convexas de canales, o en otras palabras, promediándolos
entre sí, y el hecho de que podamos hacer esto es un aspecto importante de los canales. Para explicar esto con más detalle, comencemos con dos canales F0 y F1,
digamos, junto con un número real P entre 0 y uno. Y para ser claros, estamos asumiendo que estos dos canales tienen
el mismo sistema de entrada, que es X, así como el mismo sistema de salida, que es Y. Y ahora considera qué sucede si decidimos
aplicar el primer canal F0 con probabilidad p y de lo contrario, con la probabilidad restante 1 menos p, aplicamos
el segundo canal F1. Por ejemplo, quizás elegimos aleatoriamente un bit con esas probabilidades y luego usamos este bit aleatorio
para determinar qué canal aplicar. Al hacer esto, estamos efectivamente aplicando un nuevo canal que podríamos llamar psi,
dado por una combinación convexa de los dos canales con los que empezamos y que podemos expresar como está escrito
en pantalla. Siempre podemos tomar combinaciones lineales de mapeos lineales de esta forma, por cierto, y la forma en que una combinación lineal
de mapeos lineales se define sobre una entrada dada es que simplemente tomamos la misma combinación lineal de las salidas.
Eso puede parecer trivial, pero tiene sentido. La salida que obtenemos de este escenario hipotético es simplemente el
promedio ponderado de las salidas que obtendríamos de los dos canales originales. Sin embargo, este es un nuevo canal y
si fi0 y fi1 eran canales válidos, entonces con certeza este nuevo mapeo también será un canal válido. Otra forma de decir
eso en términos matemáticos es que el conjunto de todos los canales de un sistema de entrada dado a un sistema de salida dado es
convexo, y esa es una propiedad matemática importante de los canales. Podemos hacer esto de forma más general si tenemos M canales fi 0 hasta fi M menos uno,
junto con el vector de probabilidades que nos indica cuál es la probabilidad de cada canal, obtenemos un nuevo canal promediando los canales en consecuencia, así que
en cierto sentido, esto es una fuente inagotable de nuevos canales; por ejemplo, la clase de los llamados canales unitarios mixtos es lo que
obtenemos al tomar combinaciones convexas de canales unitarios, es decir, si tenemos M matrices unitarias u0 hasta u m menos
uno, todas del mismo tamaño, junto con el vector de probabilidades, entonces si tomamos el promedio ponderado de los canales
correspondientes a las matrices unitarias individuales, como se muestra aquí en la pantalla, obtendremos un canal, y los canales
que se pueden escribir de esta forma se llaman canales unitarios mixtos; no todo canal es un canal unitario mixto, no podemos obtener
todo canal de esta manera, pero sí aparecen con bastante frecuencia; a continuación veremos algunos ejemplos específicos
de canales; todos serán ejemplos de canales de un qubit a un qubit, que se llaman canales
de qubit para abreviar; el primero se llama canal de reinicio de qubit, y la idea es que este canal reinicia un qubit
al estado cero; aquí usamos la letra griega mayúscula Lambda para denotar este canal, y una forma de recordar lo que hace es
pensar en la esfera de Bloch: la Lambda mayúscula se parece a una flecha apuntando hacia arriba, y el estado cero está en la parte superior de la esfera de Bloch, como si
apuntara a la ubicación de la salida; la forma en que se define en términos matemáticos es que Lambda de rho es igual a la traza de rho por ket 0 bra 0, así que
si lo evaluamos en cualquier matriz de densidad rho, obtendremos el estado cero como matriz de densidad; es natural preguntarse
por qué necesitamos la traza; ¿no podríamos simplemente definir Lambda de rho como ket cero bra cero sin la traza de rho delante?
Y la respuesta a esa pregunta es no: los canales deben ser mapeos lineales y no sería lineal si quitáramos la traza de rho; ten en cuenta también que
a veces necesitamos saber cómo funciona un canal como mapeo lineal sobre entradas que no son matrices de densidad; por ejemplo, como
vimos antes, si queremos saber qué hace un canal cuando lo aplicamos a un sistema compuesto, necesitamos
evaluar ese canal en los bloques individuales de una matriz de bloques más grande; y aunque la matriz de bloques completa puede ser
una matriz de densidad, los bloques individuales generalmente no lo serán; así que veamos exactamente qué hace este canal cuando lo aplicamos
a solo una parte de un sistema compuesto, y más concretamente, qué hace cuando lo aplicamos a uno de dos qubits que
forman un ebit; para ser precisos, supongamos que A y B son qubits que, como par, están en el estado de Bell phi plus, y aplicamos Lambda
digamos al primer qubit A; para averiguar qué sucede, primero expresemos el estado phi plus como una matriz de densidad, y
para este ejemplo usemos notación directa para hacerlo; aquí está el estado phi plus como vector de estado cuántico, y esto es lo que obtenemos cuando
multiplicamos este vector por su transpuesta conjugada y lo desarrollamos todo; luego podemos aplicar el canal al primer qubit y evaluar lo que obtenemos; aquí está
Lambda aplicado al primer qubit, y esto es lo que obtenemos al evaluar cada uno de los términos: la traza de ket 0 bra 0 es uno,
y también lo es la traza de ket 1 bra 1; así que en esos dos casos la salida del canal es ket 0 bra 0, y eso explica
los dos términos en la respuesta; la traza de ket cero bra uno, en cambio, es cero, al igual que la traza de ket 1 bra cero,
así que esos dos términos se evalúan a cero y por tanto no contribuyen nada a la respuesta; ahora podemos simplificar un
poco, y lo que obtenemos es el estado cero para el primer qubit, que es A, y el estado completamente mixto para el
segundo qubit, que es B; nótese en particular que no obtuvimos un estado plus para B, lo que no habría sido necesariamente
una mala suposición si no supiéramos nada sobre matrices de densidad y simplemente miráramos la representación del vector de estado cuántico del estado; pero así no es
como funciona este canal, y no existe ningún canal que pueda funcionar de esa manera; el canal Lambda se llama canal de reinicio de qubit, pero
la forma en que funciona se parece más a tirar el qubit de entrada a la basura y reemplazarlo por un qubit nuevo en el estado cero; pero de hecho este es el
único canal de qubit que siempre da como salida el estado cero; aquí hay otro ejemplo de canal de qubit, conocido como el
canal completamente desfasante; este se denota con Delta, y la forma en que funciona es que deja las entradas diagonales
de cualquier matriz 2x2 intactas y pone a cero las entradas fuera de la diagonal; Delta es la letra griega equivalente a la D del
alfabeto latino, y es la abreviatura de diagonal, así que esa es una forma de recordar lo que hace este canal; también podemos
expresar este canal usando notación directa, como se muestra en pantalla, y para que quede claro, la salida
es siempre una matriz 2x2; en particular, los dos ceros de salida se refieren a la matriz 2x2 de todos ceros; a menudo hacemos
esto, y ya lo hemos visto antes en esta serie: el símbolo cero se usa generalmente, quizás de forma ambigua, para referirse al elemento cero
de lo que sea que estemos tratando, ya sean escalares, vectores, matrices o lo que sea; hagamos lo mismo que hicimos antes con el
canal de reinicio de qubit y veamos qué sucede si aplicamos este canal a la mitad de un ebit; la configuración es la misma, así que no voy a
repetir esa parte; el resultado es el estado mostrado en pantalla, que es esencialmente un bit aleatorio compartido; así que lo que
hizo este canal fue básicamente convertir un ebit en un par perfectamente correlacionado de bits aleatorios clásicos,
y eso es coherente con una interpretación más general de este canal: al poner a cero las entradas fuera de la diagonal de una matriz de densidad, estamos efectivamente
descartando la parte cuántica de la matriz de densidad, dejando una matriz de densidad diagonal que representa un
estado probabilístico clásico; otra forma de pensar en esto es que este canal representa un canal clásico perfecto sin ruido que transmite un bit:
si introducimos un estado cero, un estado uno o una combinación convexa de esos dos estados en el canal, ese estado sale sin cambios; pero si intentas
introducir un estado cuántico, como el estado plus, por ejemplo, es como si el canal midiera ese estado con una medición en la base estándar y luego
transmitiera el resultado clásico; un último ejemplo de canal de qubit es el canal completamente despolarizante; lo que
hace este canal es dar siempre como salida el estado completamente mixto; así que en cierto sentido es similar al canal de reinicio de qubit,
excepto que obtenemos un estado completamente mixto, bastante menos útil, en lugar de un qubit inicializado; una forma natural
de pensar en este canal es que representa una forma extrema de ruido, y en lo que respecta a los canales de qubit,
realmente no puede haber más ruido que este; no tengo un buen nemotécnico para recordar lo que hace este, salvo decir que Omega es la última
letra del alfabeto griego y a veces se asocia con el fin de todas las cosas, y quizás esto es lo que les ocurre
a todos los qubits eventualmente; en cuanto al ruido, es bastante extremo, pero algo que podemos hacer es considerar una combinación convexa
de este canal y el canal identidad, con quizás una pequeña probabilidad épsilon de despolarización
completa; esta es una forma de ruido menos extrema donde un estado de qubit dado se dejará mayormente intacto, pero existe
una pequeña probabilidad de que se vuelva completamente mixto; geométricamente podemos pensar en esto como una ligera contracción de la esfera de Bloch hacia el centro,
y por cierto, podemos hacer algo similar con el canal completamente desfasante para modelar el proceso de decoherencia, por ejemplo, donde las cosas
se vuelven ligeramente más clásicas a través de algún proceso; así que esos son tres ejemplos básicos de canales de qubit, y
volveremos a ellos principalmente como fuente de ejemplos a lo largo del resto de la lección; a continuación hablaremos de las representaciones matemáticas
de los canales, comenzando con una pregunta básica: los mapeos lineales de vectores a vectores siempre se pueden
representar mediante matrices de una manera familiar, que es que la acción del mapeo lineal se describe mediante la
multiplicación de una matriz por un vector; pero los canales son mapeos lineales de matrices a matrices, no de vectores a vectores, así que en
en general, ¿cómo podemos expresar los canales en términos matemáticos? A veces, para canales especiales, tendremos una fórmula simple
que los describe, y ese fue el caso en los ejemplos de canales de qubit que ya discutimos, pero eso no es
práctico en general, porque no siempre habrá una fórmula tan elegante. Como punto de comparación, en la formulación simplificada
de la información cuántica, usamos matrices unitarias para representar operaciones sobre vectores de estado cuántico.
Toda matriz unitaria representa una operación válida y toda operación válida puede expresarse como una matriz unitaria. Entonces,
en esencia, lo que esta pregunta plantea es cómo hacemos esto para los canales, y la respuesta es que existen de hecho múltiples formas de representar
los canales en términos matemáticos. En particular, discutiremos tres formas distintas de representar canales, que reciben su nombre
de tres personas cuyo trabajo tuvo un papel importante en su desarrollo: Stinespring, Kraus y Choi.
Primero veremos cómo funcionan estas distintas representaciones y luego, en la última parte de la lección, veremos cómo se relacionan las tres representaciones y, en
particular, cómo podemos convertir entre ellas. También veremos que estas representaciones capturan con precisión los requisitos que tenemos sobre los canales:
a saber, que son aplicaciones lineales y que siempre transforman matrices de densidad en matrices de densidad, incluso cuando
se aplican a solo una parte de un sistema compuesto. Primero están las representaciones de Stinespring. Willam Forest Stinespring
fue un matemático que no trabajó en información cuántica, y las representaciones de Stinespring, tal como las describiré,
son en cierto sentido solo un derivado de su trabajo en teoría de operadores en la década de 1950. Pero este trabajo fue sin duda
una parte importante del desarrollo de las matemáticas en las que se basan los canales cuánticos. La idea detrás de esta forma de representar canales es que todo
canal puede implementarse de cierta manera que describiré ahora. Primero formamos un sistema compuesto que consiste en la
entrada del canal que estamos implementando, junto con un sistema de espacio de trabajo inicializado. Luego se realiza una
operación unitaria sobre el sistema compuesto y, finalmente, la parte del sistema compuesto resultante
que corresponde a la salida del canal se deja intacta o se emite, y el resto se descarta o se traza. Es útil
expresar esto en forma de diagrama, y es más sencillo empezar con el caso especial en el que la entrada y la
salida son el mismo sistema. Este diagrama, por cierto, es igual que un diagrama de circuit cuántico, salvo que los cables
representan sistemas arbitrarios y no necesariamente qubits individuales. Así que empezamos con el sistema de entrada X en algún
estado rho, introducimos un sistema de espacio de trabajo W inicializado y, en este diagrama, supongo que cero es un estado clásico
de W y tomamos k0 como el estado inicializado del sistema, aunque también podríamos fijar cualquier estado puro
de W y tomarlo como el estado inicializado. Luego realizamos alguna operación unitaria sobre el par WX y después
trazamos el sistema de espacio de trabajo y emitimos X. En el diagrama, por cierto, estoy usando el símbolo de tierra de la
ingeniería eléctrica para indicar que W está siendo descartado. Eso no es necesariamente convencional y no lo
encontrarás en Qiskit; allí simplemente ignoras los qubits que no te interesan. La cuestión es que solo quiero tener un símbolo que deje
claro que estamos descartando el sistema a los efectos de esta discusión. En general, no es necesario que la
entrada y la salida sean el mismo sistema, así que podemos tener, por ejemplo, un sistema de salida Y junto con un sistema de basura
G que se traza. Para que U sea unitaria, tiene que ser una matriz cuadrada, por lo que hay una suposición
aquí de que el par G,Y en conjunto tiene el mismo número de estados clásicos que el par WX. Por ejemplo, quizás estos sistemas
están formados por qubits y el sistema de entrada X consta de 5 qubits y W consta de 10 qubits, digamos, de modo que U es una operación unitaria
sobre 15 qubits. Podría ser entonces que Y conste de solo cuatro qubits, lo que significa que G consta de 11 qubits.
O quizás no sean qubits en absoluto. Lo único importante es que WX en conjunto y GY en conjunto tengan el mismo número de
estados clásicos, para que U pueda ser unitaria. Una descripción de un canal como esta se llama representación de Stinespring del canal. Ahora bien,
es bastante sencillo argumentar que toda aplicación phi que pueda describirse de esta manera es de hecho un canal válido. En
particular, si empezamos con la matriz de densidad y luego añadimos un sistema de espacio de trabajo adicional, sin duda nos
quedará una matriz de densidad. Ya observamos que aplicar una operación unitaria nos da un canal válido y,
si tenemos una matriz de densidad de un sistema compuesto y trazamos uno de los sistemas, de nuevo nos quedará una matriz de densidad. Así que cuando componemos
estos pasos, tenemos garantizado que siempre transforma matrices de densidad en matrices de densidad. Y también es lineal.
Lo que no está nada claro en este punto es que todo canal pueda implementarse efectivamente de esta manera para alguna elección
del sistema de espacio de trabajo y del sistema de basura, así como de la operación unitaria U, por supuesto. Pero eso es verdad, y
veremos por qué al final de la lección. Aquí hay un ejemplo de una representación de Stinespring para el canal de qubit de
desfasado completo. Y para ser claros, ahora los cables son qubits y esto es una compuerta controlada
NOT ordinaria. Es muy sencillo: el qubit de entrada está arriba e introducimos un qubit de espacio de trabajo inicializado al estado cero.
Luego realizamos una operación NOT controlada donde el qubit de entrada es el control y el qubit de espacio de trabajo es el
objetivo, y después el qubit de espacio de trabajo se traza. Intuitivamente, tiene sentido
que esto implemente el canal de desfasado completo, porque la compuerta NOT controlada actúa de forma parecida a una medición en la base estándar sobre el qubit superior,
copiando su estado clásico en el qubit inferior, y luego el resultado se descarta.
Pero también podemos hacer un cálculo, y por supuesto es buena idea hacerlo, porque realmente
no deberíamos confiar demasiado en nuestra intuición. Podemos empezar escribiendo la representación de matriz de densidad de los
dos qubits después de introducir el qubit de espacio de trabajo, y nótese que estamos usando la convención de ordenamiento de qubit como
de costumbre, donde el qubit inferior es el de la izquierda y el qubit superior es el de la derecha. Podemos expresar esta matriz de densidad
explícitamente como una matriz 4x4 real, tal como se muestra en pantalla, y luego calculamos el efecto
que la compuerta NOT controlada tiene sobre esta matriz de densidad. Así que conjugamos por la matriz unitaria asociada a esta
compuerta, teniendo en cuenta de nuevo la convención de ordenamiento de qubit. Esta es la matriz unitaria correcta
y el resultado se muestra aquí. En efecto, la compuerta NOT controlada
permutó un poco las entradas de nuestra matriz original, así que ahora las entradas posiblemente no nulas están en las
cuatro esquinas. Falta calcular la traza parcial, y podríamos hacerlo directamente desde la matriz, pero una
alternativa es convertir a la notación directa tal como se muestra en pantalla, y entonces resulta bastante fácil evaluar
qué ocurre cuando trazamos el qubit de la izquierda en cada término. El resultado es que solo sobreviven los
términos correspondientes a las entradas diagonales de rho, y así hemos desfasado el qubit como
era de esperar. Como siempre, comprueba esto tú mismo a tu propio ritmo si decides hacerlo. Es un buen
ejemplo para practicar el trabajo con matrices de densidad y con trazas parciales.
trazas, pero esa no es la única forma de implementar el canal completamente defasante. Aquí hay una representación de Stinespring alternativa para este
canal. No voy a repasar el cálculo en detalle en este video, pero lo mostraré brevemente por si quieres pausar el video y echarle un
vistazo más detenido. La forma en que funciona es similar a la primera, pero los detalles son
diferentes. Esta vez empezamos con un gate Hadamard en el qubit del espacio de trabajo, lo que lo pone en el estado más, y si
expandimos el producto tensorial obtenemos la matriz que se muestra en la pantalla. Para aplicar el gate Z controlado,
conjugamos con la matriz unitaria asociada, y el resultado de hacer eso es inyectar algunos signos negativos en la
matriz. En particular, la última fila y la última columna se multiplican ambas por menos 1.
Y esta vez sería bastante engorroso convertir a notación de Dirac, así que calcularemos la traza parcial
directamente. Cuando trazamos el primero de dos qubits, lo que obtenemos es la suma de los dos bloques diagonales de 2x2,
y así el resultado final es, una vez más, que hemos defasado el qubit. Eso fue rápido, y si no estás
acostumbrado a este tipo de cálculos, tómate tu tiempo y hazlo despacio. La velocidad no es importante.
Ahora, para terminar este ejemplo, déjame mencionar que hay una idea bastante sencilla detrás de esta implementación, que queda
expresada de forma muy elegante en el último paso del cálculo que acabamos de repasar. Una manera más concisa de decir esto
es que si promediamos una matriz de densidad de un qubit dado con esa matriz de densidad conjugada por la matriz Z de Pauli, entonces
eso equivale al defasamiento. Así que el canal completamente defasante resulta ser un canal unitario mixto
en el que o bien no hacemos nada —es decir, realizamos la operación identidad— o bien realizamos un gate Z, cada uno
con probabilidad 1/2. Bueno saberlo. En resumen, tenemos dos representaciones de Stinespring distintas
del canal completamente defasante, y eso nos dice algo importante: que las representaciones de Stinespring
no son únicas, y de hecho hay infinitas de ellas para cualquier canal dado. A continuación, hablamos de las representaciones de Kraus
de los canales, que nos ofrecen una manera formulaica conveniente de expresar canales mediante multiplicación
y suma de matrices. Las representaciones de Kraus llevan el nombre de Karl Kraus, un físico que, entre
otras cosas, desarrolló muchos de los detalles matemáticos básicos de los canales y la formulación general de la información cuántica de forma más amplia. En general, una
representación de Kraus es una expresión de un canal que adopta la forma que se muestra aquí en la pantalla. En particular, tenemos una
colección de matrices, que aquí se denominan A₀ hasta Aₙ₋₁ para algún entero positivo n, y especifican la
acción del canal sobre cualquier entrada ρ dada según la fórmula. En resumen, conjugamos ρ con cada una de estas matrices,
que en este contexto suelen llamarse matrices de Kraus, y luego sumamos el resultado para obtener la salida. Todas estas matrices deben tener
las mismas dimensiones y, específicamente, sus columnas deben corresponder a los estados clásicos del sistema de entrada, y
las filas deben corresponder a los estados clásicos del sistema de salida. Si ese es el caso, cuando tomamos el producto Aₖ * ρ * Aₖ† para cualquier
elección de k, obtenemos una matriz cuadrada cuyas filas y columnas corresponden a los estados clásicos del sistema de salida,
y por eso tiene sentido que la expresión produzca una matriz de densidad del sistema de salida. Ahora bien, no es el caso
de que con una elección arbitraria de estas matrices de Kraus obtengamos un canal válido. Sin embargo, hay una condición bastante sencilla
sobre las matrices que garantiza que obtendremos un canal válido, y esa condición es la fórmula que se muestra justo aquí.
Concretamente, si sumamos el producto de Aₖ† * Aₖ para todos los valores de k,
debemos obtener la matriz identidad, que será la matriz identidad cuyas filas y columnas corresponden a los
estados clásicos del sistema de entrada. Así que esa condición debe cumplirse para que la transformación definida por la
primera ecuación sea un canal válido. Y resulta que todo canal tiene de hecho una representación que adopta
esta forma, siempre que tomemos n suficientemente grande. Aquí hay algunos ejemplos de representaciones de Kraus,
empezando por el canal de reset de qubit. Podemos obtener una representación de Kraus para este canal usando
dos matrices de Kraus: |0⟩⟨0| y |0⟩⟨1|, así que n es igual a dos en este ejemplo.
Podemos sustituir estas elecciones en la fórmula general y tenemos solo dos términos, así que es fácil escribir la suma.
Y si simplificamos y reconocemos que la expresión entre paréntesis es la traza de ρ, vemos que obtenemos
el canal de reset de qubit. También podemos verificar que la condición requerida sobre estas matrices se cumple, y eso es simplemente cuestión de sustituir las matrices de Kraus
en la ecuación y evaluar, y obtenemos la matriz identidad tal como se requiere. Como otro ejemplo, volvamos a mirar el
canal completamente defasante. Tomar las matrices |0⟩⟨0| y |1⟩⟨1| funciona, y eso se puede verificar
expandiendo la suma y comprobando bastante directamente que obtenemos lo que necesitamos. Y de nuevo, la condición requerida se cumple. Una
alternativa es tomar A₀ como la matriz identidad dividida por √2 y A₁ como
Sigma Z dividida por √2, y si evaluamos vemos que de nuevo obtenemos el canal completamente defasante, basándonos en la observación
que hicimos sobre este canal un poco antes en la lección. Y una vez más, la condición requerida es bastante sencilla de
verificar. Como ejercicio para practicar, si te resultara útil, considera el canal completamente despolarizante,
que produce el estado completamente mixto para toda entrada de matriz de densidad. Para este se necesitan cuatro matrices de Kraus:
no es posible encontrar una representación de Kraus donde n sea tres o menos. Aquí hay una elección que funciona, y
aquí hay otra. El ejercicio consiste en verificar que estas elecciones funcionan, así como en comprobar que la condición requerida
se cumple. Vale la pena señalar que la segunda alternativa básicamente dice que es posible despolarizar completamente un qubit —o, en otras palabras,
aleatorizarlo por completo— eligiendo aleatoriamente una de las cuatro matrices de Pauli, incluida la identidad, y aplicando la
operación unitaria correspondiente al qubit. Así que el canal completamente despolarizante es otro ejemplo de canal
unitario mixto. La última de las tres representaciones de canal que veremos es la representación de Choi. Man-Duen Choi
es un matemático que trabaja en teoría de matrices y otros temas, y la representación de Choi lleva su nombre,
basándose en un artículo realmente elegante que publicó en 1975 que, en cierto sentido, une todo esto. La representación de Choi
de un canal Φ es una única matriz que se denota convencionalmente J(Φ), y concretamente, si el
sistema de entrada tiene n estados clásicos y el sistema de salida tiene m estados clásicos, entonces la representación de Choi de Φ será
una matriz cuadrada de n*m por n*m. Antes de decirte exactamente cómo se define la matriz, me gustaría mencionar un par de
sus propiedades clave, que motivan la representación de una manera que la propia definición quizás no lo haga, al menos en la
superficie. En primer lugar, a diferencia de las representaciones de Stinespring y de las representaciones de Kraus, la representación de Choi
es una representación llamada "fiel", lo que significa que cada canal tiene exactamente una, y eso es bastante importante,
porque dice que dos canales son iguales si y solo si sus representaciones de Choi son iguales. Así que si
tienes dos descripciones distintas de canales, como dos representaciones de Stinespring diferentes o dos representaciones de Kraus diferentes, o quizás una de
cada tipo, y quieres saber si en realidad son el mismo canal, simplemente puedes calcular la representación de Choi y
comprobar si son iguales. La segunda propiedad es que es sencillo verificar condiciones sobre la representación de Choi que son verdaderas si y solo si
tenemos un canal válido. Esa propiedad no es del todo especial, podemos decir lo mismo sobre las otras dos representaciones, pero es una buena propiedad
tenerla de todas formas, y la discutiremos con más detalle en breve. Una cosa más que hay que notar sobre la representación de Choi es que aunque estamos
representando un canal mediante una matriz, esta matriz no representa directamente el canal como una aplicación lineal. De hecho,
es más natural asociar la representación de Choi con la matriz de densidad que representa un cierto estado
que pensar en la representación de Choi como una aplicación lineal. Sin embargo, es posible recuperar la acción del canal a partir de
su representación de Choi usando una fórmula bastante sencilla, pero no es tan simple como una multiplicación matricial ordinaria.
Con eso es suficiente de preámbulo. Vamos a la definición real. Supongamos que tenemos un canal fi de un sistema X a un sistema Y
y asumimos que el conjunto de estados clásicos del sistema de entrada X es Sigma. No vamos a necesitar referirnos al conjunto de estados clásicos del sistema de salida, así que
para la definición no hace falta nombrar ese. La representación de Choi de fi se define entonces por la expresión
que se muestra aquí en la pantalla. Tenemos una suma que recorre todos los estados clásicos A y B del sistema de entrada, y estamos
sumando k a bra B tensoriado con el canal fi aplicado a k a bra B. Entonces, esta
representación se define por una fórmula, y hay un par de formas distintas de pensar en esta fórmula. Pero antes de discutirlas, permíteme
mencionar que a veces la representación de Choi se define de manera ligeramente diferente, donde el orden de los dos factores tensoriales se invierte, lo que significa
que fi de k a bra aparece como el primer factor tensorial en lugar del segundo. Pero las dos formas de hacerlo son
equivalentes salvo por esta simetría simple. Lo que eso implica es que cuando uses esta representación, es una buena
idea aclarar qué orden estás usando. Este orden es el que se utiliza en qiskit y también es mejor para
describir la representación visualmente en términos de matrices de bloques. Así que este es el que vamos a usar. Para ser más precisos sobre la descripción de la matriz de bloques,
si asumimos que el conjunto de estados clásicos Sigma consiste en los enteros desde cero hasta n menos uno
para algún entero positivo n, entonces podemos escribir jfi alternativamente como una matriz de bloques, tal como se muestra aquí en la
pantalla. En otras palabras, la representación de Choi de fi es la matriz que obtenemos evaluando fi en cada una de las
matrices de entrada que tienen exactamente una entrada igual a uno con todas las demás entradas en cero, y luego organizándolas
en una matriz de manera bastante natural. Puede que a priori no quede claro por qué querríamos formar una matriz así, pero
resulta ser muy útil. Una cosa que hay que notar es que el conjunto que contiene las matrices k a bra b cuando
a y b recorren todos los enteros de 0 a n menos uno forma una base para el espacio de todas las matrices de n por n. Así que si
tienes esta matriz, ciertamente puedes determinar lo que fi hace a una matriz arbitraria de n por n por linealidad,
específicamente tomando combinaciones lineales apropiadas de los bloques. Entonces la matriz jfi de hecho determina de manera única
a fi como una aplicación lineal. Otra forma de pensar en la representación de Choi de un canal es que
representa un estado como una matriz de densidad cuando se normaliza, específicamente dividiéndola por el número de
estados clásicos del sistema de entrada, que seguiré denotando por n en minúscula. Esto siempre nos dará una
matriz de densidad, que a menudo se llama el estado de Choi del canal. Aquí está cómo funciona esto con más detalle.
Imagina primero que tenemos dos copias idénticas del sistema de entrada y consideramos el vector de estado cuántico s
que se muestra en la pantalla, el cual representa un llamado estado maximalmente entrelazado de este par de sistemas idénticos. Para
este caso, si Sigma es el alfabeto binario, entonces esto es un estado f+, pero podemos pensar en un estado definido de manera análoga para
cualquier elección de Sigma, y lo que obtenemos es un estado muy entrelazado y, de hecho, es tan entrelazado como se puede
dado esta elección de sistemas. Para obtener la representación en matriz de densidad del estado, multiplicamos el vector de estado por su transpuesta conjugada, como de costumbre, y
así es como se ve. Y finalmente, si pensamos en la representación de Choi del canal dividida por n, vemos que es el estado que
obtendríamos si aplicáramos el canal fi al segundo sistema. En forma de figura, aquí está
cómo se ve: tenemos dos copias del sistema X en este estado maximalmente entrelazado s. El canal f
se aplica al segundo sistema, que es el de arriba en el diagrama, y el estado resultante es el estado de Choi de fi. Por supuesto, normalmente no
le daríamos el mismo nombre a dos sistemas distintos, ya que en general no es útil darle el mismo nombre a dos cosas diferentes, pero tiene sentido
en este caso, solo para establecer esta conexión con las representaciones de Choi. Hay un par de implicaciones que podemos extraer de inmediato de esta forma de
ver las representaciones de Choi. Una es que, dado que el estado de Choi es una matriz de densidad, asumiendo que f es un
canal válido, concluimos que la representación de Choi de fi debe ser semidefinida positiva. Recuerda que es un
requisito que imponemos a los canales que siempre transformen matrices de densidad en matrices de densidad, y esto
es solo un caso especial de eso. La segunda implicación es que si tomamos el estado de Choi para cualquier canal fi y
luego descartamos el sistema de salida y, necesariamente nos quedamos con el estado completamente mezclado en el sistema de entrada X.
Esto se debe a que aplicar un canal a un sistema y luego desechar el sistema resultante es equivalente a simplemente desechar el sistema original,
y si hiciéramos eso con nuestro estado maximalmente entrelazado, la matriz de densidad con la que nos quedaríamos sería
la matriz identidad dividida por n, o en otras palabras, el estado completamente mezclado para el sistema X. La idea en términos
más matemáticos es que componer cualquier canal con la traza en el sistema de salida debe ser igual a la traza en el
sistema de entrada, y eso se debe a que los canales deben preservar la traza en virtud del hecho de que son aplicaciones lineales que
siempre transforman matrices de densidad en matrices de densidad. Una vez que tenemos esta ecuación, podemos eliminar el denominador n
de ambos lados para obtener una condición un poco más limpia. En palabras, realizar la traza parcial en el sistema de salida
de la representación de Choi de un canal debe darnos la matriz identidad en el sistema de entrada. Entonces, en resumen, las representaciones de Choi
de los canales son siempre semidefinidas positivas, y si trazamos el sistema de salida, necesariamente
nos quedamos con la matriz identidad en el sistema de entrada. Como resulta, estas no son solo condiciones necesarias, sino
que también son suficientes, lo que significa que si fi es alguna aplicación lineal arbitraria y estas dos condiciones se cumplen,
entonces fi debe ser de hecho un canal válido, y veremos por qué ese es el caso al final de la lección.
Veamos algunos ejemplos, empezando con el canal de desfasado completo. Para calcular la representación de Choi es simplemente cuestión de
evaluar la fórmula. El canal de desfasado completo deja k a bra B sin cambios cuando a es igual a B, y en caso contrario la salida
es cero. Entonces los términos de la suma que sobreviven son aquellos donde a es igual a B, y el resultado se expresa en la
pantalla usando notación directa. También podemos verlo como una matriz de bloques: Delta deja las entradas diagonales sin cambios y pone a cero las entradas fuera de la diagonal
entradas diagonales y nos quedamos con una matriz que tiene unos en las esquinas superior izquierda e inferior derecha, con todas las
entradas restantes siendo cero, lo que es consistente con la primera expresión. Para otro ejemplo, consideremos nuevamente el canal completamente despolarizante:
podemos empezar escribiendo la fórmula y, igual que en el ejemplo anterior, no obtenemos ninguna contribución a la suma
cuando a no es igual a B, y esta vez cuando a es igual a B obtenemos el estado completamente mixto, que podemos simplificar a
1/2 por la matriz identidad 2x2 en producto tensorial consigo misma, que es 1/2 por la
matriz identidad 4x4. También podemos pensarlo en términos de matrices por bloques y, naturalmente, obtenemos el mismo resultado. Y como
último ejemplo, consideremos el canal identidad para un solo qubit. Es sencillo: aquí está la fórmula, y por supuesto
el canal identidad no hace nada en absoluto, y podemos interpretar el resultado como el doble de la matriz de densidad asociada a un estado f+. Eso es
consistente con lo que esperamos al pensar en el estado de elección de este canal, y aquí está como matriz por bloques. Nota en particular que la representación de Choi
del canal identidad no es la matriz identidad, sino esta otra matriz. Ya hemos visto tres formas diferentes
de representar canales matemáticamente: las representaciones de Stinespring, las representaciones de Kraus y las representaciones de Choi.
También tenemos la definición de canal, que es que un canal es un mapeo lineal que siempre
transforma matrices de densidad en matrices de densidad, incluso cuando el canal se aplica solo a una parte de un sistema compuesto. Una pregunta muy natural e importante
que surge en este punto es: ¿cómo sabemos que todas estas cosas son equivalentes? Por ejemplo, ¿cómo sabemos que cada
mapeo descrito por cualquiera de estas representaciones es en efecto un canal válido, y cómo sabemos que no estamos dejando ningún canal fuera? El
resto de la lección describe cómo se puede razonar todo esto matemáticamente. Si estás dispuesto a aceptar la equivalencia de estas cosas y no te interesa cómo se puede
razonar, puedes saltarte el resto del video. Pero personalmente creo que el argumento es bastante
elegante y es un buen ejemplo de un estilo particular de demostración matemática que aparece de vez en cuando en la teoría de la información cuántica. No voy a repasar
todos los detalles; algunos los dejo para ti, o puedes encontrarlos en el contenido escrito de esta lección, donde todo está explicado
en detalle. Pero espero presentar una imagen razonablemente clara de cómo funciona todo. Lo que queremos hacer es demostrar la
equivalencia de un conjunto de enunciados, y la forma de hacerlo es establecer un ciclo de implicaciones. En particular, vamos a empezar
con la definición de canal, es decir, un mapeo lineal que siempre transforma matrices de densidad en matrices de densidad.
A partir de esta definición podemos razonar que la representación de Choi de este canal debe satisfacer las dos condiciones que hemos
discutido antes, y de hecho ya lo hemos hecho: esto se trató en el contexto del estado de Choi de un canal. Luego olvidamos todo
lo de la definición y trabajamos desde la representación de Choi, y dadas nuestras dos condiciones sobre las representaciones de Choi, concluimos que debe existir una
representación de Kraus del mapeo fi. Luego hacemos algo análogo: olvidamos las representaciones de Choi y trabajamos
a partir de una representación de Kraus arbitraria, y a partir de ella podemos razonar que debe existir una representación de Stinespring para el mapeo fi. Por cierto, estos
argumentos serán mecánicos en cierto sentido, lo que nos permite realizar las conversiones siguiendo las flechas para canales específicos si queremos
hacerlo. La última implicación consiste en razonar que si tenemos una representación de Stinespring para un mapeo fi, entonces
ese mapeo debe ser en efecto un canal válido, y esto también lo hemos hecho antes, esta vez en el contexto de las representaciones de Stinespring.
En conjunto, estas cuatro implicaciones revelan que estas cuatro cosas son todas equivalentes, porque puedes empezar por cualquiera de ellas y
seguir las implicaciones de forma transitiva para llegar a cualquiera de las otras. Empezaremos con la primera implicación,
que dice que si tenemos un canal fi, es decir, un mapeo lineal que siempre transforma matrices de densidad en matrices de densidad, entonces tiene una representación de Choi
que satisface las dos condiciones que identificamos antes, a saber, que es semidefinida positiva
y que si trazamos el sistema de salida obtenemos la identidad sobre el sistema de entrada. Como mencioné hace un momento,
ya cubrimos esta implicación en el contexto de los estados de Choi. En particular, cuando dividimos la representación de Choi de un canal por n, el número de
estados clásicos del sistema de entrada, obtenemos una matriz de densidad, y además el estado reducido del
sistema X para ese estado es el estado completamente mixto, o en otras palabras, la matriz identidad dividida por n. Despejar el denominador nos da nuestras
dos condiciones, así que esta implicación es bastante rápida y sencilla porque ya la habíamos cubierto.
Ahora veamos la segunda implicación. Esta vez empezamos con la representación de Choi de un mapeo que
suponemos que satisface los dos requisitos, y nuestro objetivo es encontrar una representación de Kraus para este mapeo que
satisfaga el requisito del que hablamos antes. Esta implicación es bastante mecánica en cierto sentido; necesitaremos un
poco de álgebra lineal y se reducirá principalmente a manipular matrices y vectores de una manera bastante ingeniosa.
Comienza con la suposición de que la representación de Choi es semidefinida positiva, que es el primero de los dos requisitos que estamos asumiendo que están
vigentes. La noción de matriz semidefinida positiva es fundamentalmente importante en la información cuántica, y no solo en el contexto de las matrices de densidad:
es absolutamente crítica aquí; no podríamos hacer que esto funcionara sin ella. En particular, la suposición
de que jfi es semidefinida positiva nos permite expresarla en la forma que se muestra en pantalla para alguna elección de
vectores s0 hasta S N menos uno, y alguna elección de un entero positivo n. Hay que notar explícitamente que estos no son
necesariamente vectores unitarios. Una forma de obtener una expresión como esta es a partir del teorema espectral para matrices semidefinidas positivas,
que se discutió en la lección anterior. Aquí no vemos valores propios apareciendo explícitamente como en una descomposición espectral,
pero recuerda que los valores propios de las matrices semidefinidas positivas son siempre números reales no negativos, y también ten en cuenta que no estamos
exigiendo que estos vectores s0 hasta S N menos uno sean vectores unitarios. Entonces lo que podemos hacer es tomar las raíces cuadradas de
los valores propios y multiplicarlos por los vectores propios unitarios que obtenemos de una descomposición espectral para obtener estos
vectores s0 hasta S N menos uno. En realidad no es importante para esta demostración que estos vectores sean ortogonales —sí
lo obtenemos de una descomposición espectral, pero no lo vamos a usar aquí— y si tuviéramos alguna otra expresión de jfi como esta que no viniese del
teorema espectral, también estaría bien. Ahora descomponemos cada uno de estos vectores como se muestra en pantalla,
igual que haríamos si estos vectores fueran vectores de estado cuántico de un par de sistemas XY y estuviéramos
realizando una medición en la base estándar sobre el sistema X. Para ser claros, aquí no estamos midiendo nada; solo estamos escribiendo estos vectores en esta forma, lo cual
siempre es posible. Y ahora viene el truco: definimos las matrices de Kraus a0 hasta a n menos uno extrayendo las K
A's del frente de estos vectores s0 hasta S N menos uno, dándoles la vuelta para que se conviertan en bra A's en vez de
ket A's, y colocándolos a la derecha como se muestra en la ecuación en pantalla. Una forma de pensar en
esto es que básicamente estamos plegando estos vectores para formar matrices, de modo que si apiláramos las columnas de AK una encima de otra, obtendríamos
de vuelta s. Así que estas matrices tienen exactamente las mismas entradas que los vectores correspondientes, solo que hemos
reorganizado las entradas de forma diferente para obtener matrices. Pero también podemos pensar en estas matrices de forma puramente simbólica en términos de notación de Dirac,
como está escrito aquí. Y ahora en este punto surge una pregunta obvia: ¿por qué debería funcionar esto? Bueno, no nos detengamos demasiado
sobre por qué funciona, simplemente verifiquemos que sí lo hace. Para eso, definamos un nuevo mapeo, que es el mapeo definido por
estas matrices, donde las tratamos como matrices cruzadas. Lo que podemos hacer ahora es calcular la representación de Choy de
este nuevo mapeo y veremos que es igual a la representación de Choy del mapeo F con el que empezamos, y
como las representaciones de Choy son fieles, esto significa que los dos mapeos son de hecho iguales. No voy a repasar el álgebra en este video;
puedes verificarlo tú mismo. Es bastante mecánico y es un buen ejercicio, y todo lo que necesitas para eso está justo
aquí en la pantalla. Todavía no hemos dicho nada sobre las dos condiciones secundarias en los dos recuadros, pero resulta
que son equivalentes, y una forma de establecer eso es verificar la ecuación que se muestra aquí en la parte inferior de la
pantalla. La letra T aquí, por cierto, se refiere a la transposición matricial, que también puedes pensar como el
mapeo lineal que convierte k a bra B en k b bra a, y simplemente es algo que se necesita para que la fórmula funcione. Así que, en
resumen, definitivamente se necesita algo de álgebra para esta implicación, pero como dije, es todo bastante mecánico.
Básicamente es gimnasia de índices, como algunos lo llaman, pero si lo trabajas y le das a tu cerebro la oportunidad de asimilarlo, puede que
salgas con una mejor comprensión de cómo se relacionan las representaciones de Choy y las representaciones cruzadas. La tercera implicación nos permite
pasar de una representación cruzada de un mapeo fi, donde está en vigor la condición habitual, a una representación de Stein spring. Esta es bastante
similar en espíritu a la implicación anterior, en el sentido de que es mecánica y puede verse y verificarse en términos puramente algebraicos.
La idea es en realidad bastante simple: lo que podemos hacer es tomar nuestras matrices cruzadas y formar parte de una matriz mayor apilándolas
una sobre otra, como se muestra en la pantalla. Una vez completada, esto nos dará la matriz unitaria U para una
representación de Stein spring. Las matrices unitarias deben ser matrices cuadradas, así que tendremos que completar todas las columnas restantes
que necesitemos, pero en realidad no importa cuáles sean, siempre que obtengamos una matriz
unitaria. Si por un momento dejamos de lado la preocupación de que U sea unitaria y simplemente nos enfocamos en el mapeo lineal que está definido por
la representación de Stein spring que obtenemos de esta matriz U, lo que encontramos es que el mapeo es igual al
mapeo original fi definido por la representación cruzada con la que empezamos. Esa es otra parte de la demostración que no voy a repasar en este video;
puedes encontrar los detalles en el contenido escrito de esta lección, pero también puedes tomarte un tiempo y trabajarlo tú mismo. Solo ten
en cuenta, como de costumbre en la serie, que estamos usando la convención de ordenación de kets para interpretar el diagrama, así que w y G
corresponderán a los factores tensoriales del lado izquierdo en las ecuaciones. Y por cierto, si lo trabajas
encontrarás que, como tenemos k0o bra cero como factor tensorial del lado izquierdo en la ecuación
que necesitamos verificar, la única parte de U que tiene relevancia es la parte dada por la matriz CR. Así que, siempre que
completemos las columnas de U de manera que sea unitaria, estamos bien. Pero claro, esto requiere que las columnas formadas por a0 hasta a n menos
uno, al apilarlas una sobre otra, sean ortonormales, y aquí es donde entra en juego la condición que imponemos a las representaciones cruzadas.
Y en efecto, es precisamente equivalente a que las columnas sean ortonormales. Las relaciones matemáticas relevantes necesarias para llegar a esta
conclusión se muestran aquí abajo en la parte inferior de la pantalla. Así que adelante, pausa y verifica si quieres, o
consulta el contenido escrito para más detalles. En resumen, lo que está pasando aquí, tanto en esta implicación como en la
anterior, es que estamos describiendo las mismas operaciones matemáticas de maneras distintas pero equivalentes.
El corazón de todo ello es esencialmente la multiplicación matricial. La cuarta y última implicación establece que si tenemos
una representación de Stein spring para algún mapeo, entonces ese mapeo debe ser de hecho un canal válido; y como indiqué
antes, ya cubrimos esta implicación cuando discutimos las representaciones de Stein spring. En resumen y en
términos ligeramente distintos: introducir un sistema de espacio de trabajo inicializado es un canal válido, porque tensorizar una matriz de densidad fija
con una matriz de densidad dada siempre nos da una matriz de densidad, y es un mapeo lineal por la bilinealidad
de los productos tensoriales. Las operaciones unitarias son siempre canales válidos, como comenté antes en la lección. Trazar un sistema es un canal válido porque la
traza parcial es un mapeo lineal que siempre transforma matrices de densidad en matrices de densidad. Y finalmente, las composiciones de
canales son siempre canales, lo cual es bastante simple pero definitivamente vale la pena señalar por derecho propio. Y con las
cuatro implicaciones que acabamos de cubrir, hemos establecido la equivalencia de nuestras tres representaciones de canales junto con la
definición original de canal. En particular, empezamos con la definición de canal, vimos cómo esa definición implica que su representación de Choy
satisface necesariamente dos condiciones básicas, luego vimos cómo esas condiciones nos permiten encontrar una representación de Krauss, que a su vez
nos permite encontrar una representación de Stein spring, y finalmente vimos que la existencia de una representación de Stein spring revela que sí tenemos
de hecho un canal válido. Por supuesto, hay detalles técnicos y no es necesariamente sencillo, especialmente
cuando lo ves por primera vez, pero lo que es interesante y destacable aquí es que estas implicaciones están planteadas de una manera que de hecho hace
las cosas lo más fáciles posible, y en matemáticas nunca deberías sentir vergüenza por tomar el camino más fácil. Por
ejemplo, no es para nada obvio que todo canal tenga una representación de Stein spring o una representación de Krauss,
pero es relativamente fácil concluir que la representación de Choy de todo canal satisface las dos condiciones que le hemos asociado, y eso
nos permite seguir un camino más o menos algebraico hacia las otras dos representaciones. En una línea similar,
la última implicación, de la representación de Stein spring de vuelta a la definición, también es relativamente directa, y
nos permite concluir que solo obtenemos canales y ningún otro tipo de mapeo de las representaciones de Choy, siempre que se cumplan las
condiciones requeridas. Y como mencioné antes, la forma en que argumentamos estas implicaciones es suficientemente mecánica para permitirnos convertir fácilmente
entre las representaciones, y si vuelves a algunos de los ejemplos que cubrimos antes en la lección, encontrarás que de hecho es posible
convertir entre representaciones, a veces de forma bastante fácil y directa. Y eso es el final de la
lección, que ha sido toda sobre canales. Hablamos sobre qué son y vimos algunos ejemplos básicos, discutimos tres formas en que los canales pueden
representarse y profundizamos en algunos detalles técnicos que establecen la equivalencia de estas representaciones.
Espero que te unas a mí en la próxima lección, que trata sobre las mediciones en la formulación general de la información cuántica. ¡Hasta luego!